1 2 3 4
faire une crème fouettée à l'huile de
bras peut-être rigolo mais ça peut être
long et rendu tout dépend du fouet
Jean-Philippe Monet nous aide à trouver
le meilleur
ustensile en mettant à l'épreuve 15 fois
entre 8 et 30 dollars
pourquoi j'aurais besoin d'un fouet en
cuisine aujourd'hui avec tous les petits
et gros électroménagers qu'on a
maintenant dans nos cuisine moi je
dirais généralement c'est plus pour les
sauces en fait donc pour monter une
petite vinaigrette rapide
c'est vrai que monter une crème fouettée
à la main ou des blancs d’œufs en neige
à la main ça ça fait un peu masochiste
pour ce banc d'essai ce sont les plus
polyvalents qui ont été testés les
fouets de forme arrondie des fois qui
sont plus étroits qui sont plus pour les
sols c'est des fois un peu plus gros
vraiment pour monter les crèmes mais
donc on essaye de trouver le compromis
entre les deux là bah oui effectivement
c'est un peu le problème les tests de
performance manovabilité et impression
de durabilité ont été menées lors de la
préparation de crème fouettée de roue et
de béchamel
mais une évaluation
ergonomique a d'abord été faite
il y a beaucoup de questions des anges
de mouvement en fait comme s'il pouvait
vous encouragez à battre en même temps
il en aura par exemple qui est en bois
moi je trouvais ça très agréable enfin
nous les cuisiniers avec les bons vieux
froids en métal peut-être que c'est plus
résistant métal mais son petit peu plus
brut dirons-nous là au niveau de la
prise en main
constant les manches des Oxo en
caoutchouc sont très agréables à
manipuler
à l'opposé un fouet aux manches trop
gros ou au design particulier offre
moins d'aisance deux j'ai l'impression
que c'est une cuillère et non pas un
fouet il se passe rien
le format de fouet fait partie des
qualités primordiales d'un gagnant comme
il est plus élancé il va aller bien dans
les coins de la casserole si on va le
poser avec un gros lourd comme ça est-ce
que ça pourrait avoir le même résultat
on y va
ça fait le travail mais ça irait pas
mieux si on amène plus grosse quantité
pour un objet aussi gros effectivement
ça sera un bon choix pour quelqu'un qui
fait dans un cuisine de haut volume ça
pourrait bien
pour ce qui est des fils d'habitude
c'est du métal de la synoxydable c'est
plutôt rare que c'est autre chose puis
l'autre fil évidemment plus ça fait de
résistance plus il y a qui va rentrer il
y a plus de mouvement savoir s'il y a
généralement 8 9 10 11 11 là
5 de nous fouet on ne fait les plus mais
là où le bas blesse c'est le silicone
qui recouvre les fils de fer parce que
le silicone doit rester assez fin le fil
de fer à l'intérieur du silicone est
encore plus fin ça donne très peu de
résistance et donc la sensation est
assez assez douce je vous dirais l'autre
c'est pas très agréable c'est quand même
pas si pire imo un peu par exemple
faut pas mettre de
pressions brouillés dans une poêle bah
oui ça pourrait être tout seul
il y a des fois qui ont des filtres très
gros très solides mais pour monter de la
crème c'est c'est carrément utopique on
pourrait penser que la colle à la
jonction des fils et du manche manque de
finition ce qui m'a de l'époxy ou de la
colle pour vraiment tenir les fils à
l'intérieur du manche et que ça se
défasse pas souvent ça donne un
indicateur de durabilité
finalement duel entre le Wiko et le Oxo
au test de la crème fouettée
je vais pas augmenter là mais ça
commence à être beau comme crème
fouettée ça ça ressemble plus à une
crème point
[Musique]
les filles sont tellement gros s'il y a
pas il y a pas de ressort il y a peu de
tension qui se passe en plus avec le
petit bout là qui vient entourer les
fils on atteint pas le ça prendrait plus
de crème on attend pas le fond de la du
cul de poule toutes les défaites sont
bonnes
je vais essayer avec lui on dirait que
prodair qui rentre plus difficile
d'aller dans le coin deux fois ont une
bille à l'intérieur des fils le Star
frites et le Fox run est-ce qu'on fait
ça
qui est quelque chose qui va lâcher de
la crème reste président
après s'être fait des muscles notre
expert arrête son choix sur quelques
fouets qui ont toutes les qualités
recherchées dans le Brown à seulement 9$
mais décidément notre expert n'a que des
éloges pour les deux aux à 14 dollars ce
sont ses coups de cœur surtout le plus
effilé des deux
que c'est plus fan de venir travailler
une sauce par exemple avec pour un fouet
le donc monter des sauces béchamel aller
dans les coins de la casserole sans que
ça colle son avantage pour moi
personnellement mais l'autre modèle
ballon et tout aussi bien ils sont ils
sont légers ils sont ils sont faciles à
manipuler la manche en silicone est
assez ergonomique c'est vraiment
agréable à travailler
je suis fier de moi c'est lequel aussi
je le veux
[Musique]